[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to what will
most likely be the shortest video I ever
made thank you all and I'll see you soon
the chest comedy video most of the jokes
are very cheesy but you know they are
kind of funny and the chest chest comedy
videos are so rare that you know I I
don't think we can really afford to be
picky and now everything is hanging this
is hanging this is hanging this is
hanging we have a four so already seems
like it's gonna be an exciting game
you're more than welcome to pause the
video here and you know try and figure
out what he played and what he played
you know those are two different things
congratulations you you are the man or
or a woman as three three points um
three point five percent of my
subscribers are women the night is no
longer defended by the pawn and now what
equal material on the board black will
be somewhat better this is actually a
complete draw because the Queen can
deliver checkmate on a trade there was
even news from some of the reporters
that that Robert Fischer booked a flight
from Reykjavik to Iceland but it was
actually some German tourists also named
Robert Fischer you know you know you
don't want to do this if you're human if
you had more time most likely you would
play it immediately this photo challenge
is a bit different but so you know I
hope I hope you will be able to do it so
here it is I hope you all ready let's go
so who is this person
hello everyone know I don't know how you
could possibly know who this is there
still moves to be played maybe maybe he
could do something I but aren't agreed
you know with himself that there is no
point in playing this he played b6 I
played 93 and here he played before so
as you can see not a formation you see
every day and now Queen to d5 with check
so what do you do here you either go
back or you go back well obviously you
know it's a very unjust life to resign a
game on most 63 if you're already almost
63 you might as well play another move
to make it 64 if captures captures and
captures you can just captures captures
and of course captures I just want to
say that being in the grip of the iron
Tiger is very dangerous and unpleasant
so make sure you watch this game from
from a safe distance I listed the
Grantchester today I thought maybe I'd
get a chance maybe to talk to some of
the players or maybe even get a photo
with them or something and 11 was really
late for the game he was running and I
tried to hold out at the board and I was
holding the pen you know maybe if he
wanted to put a signature on it while
running but he said that he was so late
that there was not enough time even for
that it's an old video I know it's hard
to watch my videos in only 30 frames per
second dabbing is super easy just bend
your elbow look into it and raise your
other arm like like this is this like
there we go now of course you don't have
time to capture the root because a
bushel captures here but you also could
do it sorry about that we have a
completely new game on our hands I would
like to address something that well some
of you have been saying in the comments
that you don't enjoy the subtitles as it
covers a well a large portion of your
screen and now we have a short castle by
Wesley yes this is a short castle and
there we have it lipstick maniac so
probably she included this in the
description so that her future opponents
know that when she is using her lip balm
or lipstick that she is not consulting a
super computer that she is just a maniac
of course all of you want to put this
spawn and then deliver mate here I know
you guys do but if you did this then
Queen d1 check and you throw the game
more fee unlike some of you who were
thinking that it will not be tricked by
such moves I'm really terrified of
sea-weed rook a to the 8th now Nakamura
grabs the open D file and we have rook 8
to F 1 now Nakamura doubles up on their
file
ahead of Canadian Grandmaster Kevin's
bracket you all know the old saying
never Google Kevin's private images look
at these bishops here it's the greatest
bishop pair ever there they're quite a
team here we have a nice close-up of
Magnus cos and it's it's like he's
saying could you please take photos of
someone else please then we have a nice
photo of Galen he just arrived at the
board with a glass of water in one hand
and a handshake in the other Andrew tank
penguin GM penguin I'm happened when
what I've prepared something for you
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
if your friends at the bar in the
library ask you about it
the first ever game between morphine was
intended in the go I do mention this to
your to your friends at the bar in the
library and I had to go out for a beer
your friends and the more so definitely
a good read and the library of
they're not good company with some nice
rockin beer your friends at the bar very
much looking forward to this book and
the library will not believe a lot of
things going up for a beer or to your
friends at the bar and just return these
books here in the library
once I open up one day or the other you
will be maybe in a bar in a library or
somewhere and you will be able to
impress your friends with your great
knowledge so thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and don't forget to show this game
to your friends at the bar in the
library that's the stuff
I don't have a photo of a young morph
even though Murphy's like eight and a
half nine years old here I did use some
image software to try and make him a
little bit younger but in the end I I
think it just thinned thinned out his
face it's just amazing this moment where
well I I forgot where the moment was
yeah I definitely think I'm gonna take a
crash course under Eddie not to be able
to survive at least until moved to the
players were taken on a yacht trip so
here we have it either have it players
are getting ready to board the Y actors
on the Maxine hurricane in the back
Wesley so ding Liron and Charlie
mamedyarov
and a suspiciously happy person standing
behind them one player who appears to be
you know extremely happy is shocked
their mom
Gerald Kirk and is not very impressed as
you know he's been on iocked plenty of
times but mama Daryl definitely looks
like someone who should have been in a
video of the Lonely Island's I'm on a
boat King be one always are useful move
unless it's not after route captors and
g3 you're just going to recapture yes
you are going to recapture sorry seems
seems the interface froze for some
reason no idea why this happened in 2020
Capablanca did not play any games no way
Jose
it's not like I find I find a good move
just try try to find something don't
have any water I forgot to pour for some
fresh water so for those of you who
found it congratulations you are you are
an engine sir you know who wouldn't
allow to chess players from entering
their country regardless of the disease
they're carrying Nikolai Russell emo was
an American French Greek Russian Grand
Master oh yeah really puts a bind and
lacks position it's very hard for black
to developed
use of the rooks and also the a75 is now
under attack meadow is seeing ghosts
obviously it's all gonna be about him he
keeps stealing the spotlight with every
game he plays and all the attention is
always on his game and as you can see
Caruana still refusing to wear his blue
blazer as he doesn't want to be mistaken
for a 1950s a hamburger joint worker a
wonderful victory for Alexander Grisha
and his and his aggressive pair so to
say we have castles by black not just by
black by but by Roy Turnbull black why
did he resign well there are there are
three Queens on the board
I was just browsing the internet as I
usually do and I came across a photo of
Carlson's sister Ingrid on Twitter and
whenever I see a photo of her I think to
myself so that's what Magnus would look
like with long hair
you all have heard the old saying the
night on the rim is grim but what about
two nights you know each on their own
Rim and here you can capture with gee
but you can also capture with the Queen
Anne depo here before deciding what he's
gonna do
he actually took a little nap here we
even have a nice photo of this moment
there you have it nipple taking a nice
nap above the board there is a pleat for
me if any of you are able to find at
least one photo of mr. Calvin's raggedly
send it to me for those of you who were
able to do it I just don't believe you
do you say hello everyone when
interacting with people in your life I
know as people we run from don't speak
English so that would be quite weird is
more feature sorry guys
so Bishop the c6 first saying that okay
you're not castling queenside and you're
definitely not castling queenside i hope
you'll enjoyed my yesterday's video if I
choose bold but it's time to get back to
our 1991 Lynne are a series featuring
also vastly untrue
so again I was very unimpressed that I
actually knew that there is a win here
because of the damn engine evaluation
what did you say so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank mmm this is I forgot to I forgot
to update my interface but I will do it
in the next video surely and don't call
me Shirley as usual you can check to all
my previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon
[Music]
you